50 goddamn seconds of Disney related
logos yeah
treachery bloodlust movie somehow knows
all three of my safe words also
narration I would make fun of carrot
days except I spent time growing up in
towns that had corn festivals strawberry
parades and deep-fried days yes it was
Indiana so even for ribbon ketchup stage
blood this is excessive this is predator
prey
an animal can be both though a fox might
eat a rabbit but an eagle can eat a fox
the moral is avoid Birds oh look a
racist Fox we have one of those in our
world too roll credits
you ever wonder how your mom and me got
to be so darn happy once and removed for
causing legit laughter and me before the
four-minute mark if you don't try
anything new you'll never fail yeah tell
that to Michael big impossible even for
you to become a police officer if the
mother's voice isn't credited to bunny
hunt I will lose all faith in humanity
your dad me or 275 brothers and sisters
requisite rabbits a lot joke present and
accounted for were four minutes into the
film it's great to have dreams yeah just
as long as you don't believe in them too
much this is honestly excellent
parenting that will surely be presented
as overly protective parenting even
though despite the movies message not
every child is a special snowflake as
printers used to eat pray so what do
they eat now am I supposed to believe
they're all vegan she read a book and
somehow became stronger and faster than
all the other recruits this is cute but
isn't a feasible representation of an
actual fight in the real world with a
rhino trust me CPD's very first rabbit
officer Judy ha
goddamn it you couldn't resist the
animal specific last name thing I
suppose the mayor here is mayor George
Rohr right also with 80-some million
rabbits and bunny town it's impossible
for them to all have pun surnames
meaning we lucked out that our main
character has one the only thing we have
to fear is fear itself
did FDR exist in this world was there an
animal world war 2 the population of
this one community is almost 80 1.5
million it's not like the Predators
didn't serve a purpose
also when other bunnies liked sex joke
hilarious I'm gonna take office soon for
some pretty inspired animal pun band
names but I'm going to immediately add
one back for Judy using what looks like
an old
shuffle with a touchscreen they couldn't
give her a fucking iPhone also I would
have thrown in Cat Stevens but that's
just me if that's a fish town market
does that mean they're buying fish at
the market to eat I guess since this is
a mammals only party the fish still get
to be food whales and seals really
lucked out on this one this song's
lyrics are dangerous and not the kind of
message I want to send to my college aid
bunny or young viewer try everything
even prostitution needle drugs Burger
King hot dogs her breasts should be down
by her groin but at least the number is
right because Zootopia made me Google
how many teats does it gazelle have you
went you little Dickens fat cop that
likes doughnuts cliche also overuse of
cliche cliche our first bunny officer
Hopps parking duty dismissed parking
duty movie wants me to feel like this is
because she's a bunny but with most
first shift cops of any race be put on
parking duty isn't it a rookie slash
hazing thing must be a giant pain for a
giraffe to go anywhere in this town
profiling that's actually disgusting we
reserve the right to refuse service to
anyone did we really need to set the
scene in a mid-century style ice-cream
parlor
it's a little on the snout isn't it are
your customers aware they're getting
snot and mucus with their cookies and
cream how could they not have been aware
did they look away the entire time there
was being prepared a jumbo pop $15
I'm sending any world where a single
jumbo pop calls 15 $15 Jesus yeah I
don't have my wallet discount fantastic
mr. Fox
why are popsicles for animals human
sized I get the lonely apartment imagery
which is intended to underscore how
helpless and hopeless she feels but why
does a bunny rent a human apartment in
Zootopia mark our grass plots to rent
carrot fields lettuce bed in breakfasts
this is basically the same room Tom
Hanks stays in and big let me guess our
am
[Music]
also super timely radio station songs
are super timely parrots are actually
high in sugar and aren't good for
rabbits though this movie decides to
cave to the history of Bugs Bunny and
carry on the lie that bunnies love
carrots
they don't carrots kill bunnies they've
eaten two XS so Q movie you've just
killed officer Hopps dickheads
she knows how they feel do they have to
be such in-your-face
assholes about it also no one in this
universe understands how being a cop
works you go to the Academy pass the
test then they give you a badge
she's a real cop it doesn't matter she's
a meter maid hilarious but how does this
tiny Mouse's tiny Mouse car navigate the
same roads as a large I'll forget it
everyone keeps hating on the bunny cop
and not recognizing the value of having
a small fast animal as a cop let's see
the Rhino do this these buildings have
no foundation allowing them to topple
like dominoes you did stop a master
criminal from stealing two dozen MODY
onions hate to disagree with you sir but
those aren't onions Judy would be
amazing at cinemasins
I thought those were onions life isn't
some cartoon musical where you sing a
little song and your insipid dreams
magically come true so let it go
in case you didn't realize frozen most
popular leads none witnesses none and
you're not in the computer system yes so
resources none
I want she's not in the computer system
she's been an employee for a little over
a day it sounds like the Zootopia PD HR
department is terrible at its job good
luck getting that first paycheck also
make us all those traffic tickets are
gonna get thrown out I'm just a dumb
bunny but we are gonna multiply har-har
bunnies have lots of sex how many times
is this movie gonna go back to that well
yes this giraffe stuffing of this hippo
volleyball is hilarious my question is
how does this match ever take place is
the Zootopia intramural League utterly
biased against hippos and other short
animals you happen to catch the license
plate number did you Tommy Chong yak
actually caught the license plate number
despite being a Tommy Chong yak they're
all sloths
hilarious DMV is slow joke from Pixar is
only about 12 years too late to be
timely but whatever good slow is slow
joke y'all three solid minutes of the
sloths they're slow joke that wasn't
even super funny to begin with my
batters in there the scene isn't for the
Godfather reference it's for the fact
that this is actually in the middle of
the night even Ethan Hawke laughs at the
x mark and a coincidence of this in
order to make sense this Disney movie is
gonna have to pass through one of those
goddamn
and Burton films zootopia's Got Talent
Jared you saved my life I'd be surprised
too the rabbit was able to hold on to
that Fox that's twice her size and then
conveniently flipped him into a series
of vines that did not immediately snap
or come loose upon their landing then
they fall into these conveniently fall
breaking leaves that keep them from
plummeting to their deaths did these
vines just break their fall and tie them
up in a spiral thing who days to find
the autumn or you quit that was the deal
badge sometimes characters and movies
are assholes just because the movie
needs a backup this is one of those
times Dan left holding both your hands
up to indicate 10 doesn't work when you
only have eight fingers being muzzled
sucks I get it but why does it take him
so long to rip that muzzle off his face
with his two good hands
no mutton chubs sheep saying this is the
equivalent of a person saying Oh meaty
ribcage where does that road go well
wherever it goes they have to be running
out of traffic cameras to look at since
I'm sure they're outside the city limits
at this point Judy a police officer
doesn't have a flashlight and has to
resort to using a phone damnit
jump-scare go back to an insidious movie
where you belong
chief BOGO handed out 14 missing mammal
files they're all here am I supposed to
believe that in this giant sprawling
city all the missing person cases are
related to this one case chief BOGO
doesn't know how handy the main
character happens to catch one of the
main bad guys on video to swim all
drains lead to the mountain they survive
this even in Zootopia celebrities
interject themselves into situations
they are unqualified to address with all
due respect a good cop is supposed to
serve and protect
I appreciate Disney trying to tackle all
these delicate social issues but I'm
afraid we're about to reach critical
mass if they start talking about Darfur
or something this movie might just
become Sean Penn no with this references
Breaking Bad I'm sorry
okay well I can cross that off the
bucket list you have a bucket list dude
ladies and gentlemen I give you speed
this movie is full of survived events
that shouldn't be survivable right get
that even in Zootopia the cops are
corrupt as this art imitating life or
life imitating art several years in
advance of said art being released main
character running away a trips on some
stupid falls down for a treat moment of
tension cliche does this museum not have
video surveillance
aren't you on camera right now laughing
about your great criminal victory over
officer Hopps actually this is some
Horrible Bosses level of thinking never
play the secret audio condemning your
foe in front of the actual vote lest
they threaten to kill you for Lady
Gaga's Elle
I immediately regret this decision ever
since cinemasins began the most
requested thing has been TV sins and now
it's a reality click the link in the
description below to check it out and
now the audio outtakes I've glimpsed our
future and all I can say is go back our
target is a major transaction of micro
processes yes those I don't know what
they are you don't know what they are
who gives a you're acting all skittish
don't worry I've been stealing birds for
living since before I could drop no one
tells me what I can or can't be
[Music]
[Applause]